wait I don't know good I'll go to their
house and then I I [ __ ] the wives what
are we doing what's going on like no
you're just building things for them oh
my God you're so stupid John he keeps
he's confused about [ __ ] yeah
you're still like uh wait so when do I
[ __ ] them is this when we start [ __ ]
[Music]
so this is a very nice and a wholesome
story oh sweet you know we're gonna keep
it wholesome wholesome there's not much
more than this photo I'm gonna show you
right now
once I get the right spacing on it
oh good enough glad you're back Joe yeah
Joe's back yeah huh nah she he's
pregnant no oh no but that looks like a
pregnancy couple photo rent my handy
husband rent my husband okay so this
married couple happily married couple
nothing fishy here no hiking stories
Julia it does look like he's pregnant
though like the way they're standing
it's an adventure okay uh this uh this
wife uh thought it would be a good idea
to rent out her husband as a handyman
because this mother of three got the
idea of this unusual side hustle after
listening to a podcast of a man making a
living putting together flat pack
furniture for other people and after
jokingly posting an ad posting about her
husband's DIY skills which include
painting decorating tiling carpet laying
skills Etc the guy's been non-stops
booked ever since and now is like
full-time full-time she runs all the
business he does the handiwork so this
makes me want to gather up all my uncles
and be like so let's get we're gonna
start a business so I'm gonna wrench I'm
gonna pimp you guys because those are
the biggest handymans in the world dude
they can fix anything dude they're hot I
think it's a personalized taskrabbit
grab it task rabbit yeah and she runs
him grab it grab it is it specifically
for like a market like like single moms
that are busy or like whatever that
would be hella funny people that
specifically are in the dudes that like
are bald that like show the top of their
ass crack when they're fixing yeah like
the profile needs to be very handy it
can be a hot like a handy guy yeah I
mean you got it that guy looks like he
could fix some [ __ ] though no no he
definitely will say he fixed some [ __ ]
you you can fix it like going with the
codes and stuff oh we can't do that
technically
[Laughter]
that's your problem lady this guy just
goes like Oh we can't do that actually
we gotta talk to the city
[Laughter]
oh that's so true yeah they always have
problems like yeah we just can't do that
that's when you know yeah
well dude every white worker like that
that has the
no trust me I get yeah but uh we can't
do that no we cannot do that oh well
first you got the architect an engineer
and then you got the city and the
building permit and the plumbing there
you go it's a process and then you know
what it's a process but your friend
Jesus said uh it was all good you know
[ __ ] that guy dude we're gonna get him
out of this country you know what I mean
all that dude full circle yeah Full
Circle Dude first Circle baby no lie
though I just had my shot built in
Hawaii and it took like a minute right
but that's because of the city and there
was mad corruption and all that and I
was like
we need some Mexicans in Hawaii
those guys and you know why because like
folks there they don't work on the
weekends they don't work overnight wow
they work just in the daytime they work
when they feel like when they feel like
it feels like an amazing work-life
balance yeah oh you know she's Mexicans
come to Hawaii
[Music]
Mexican food yeah yeah it's so easy to
like to uh hire a Mexican dude like if
you ever like as a proper company like
to come over and fix something like AC
or something like a proper company they
come in and the Mexicans like oh it's
gonna charge you this much this much
like oh [ __ ] but if you tell them like
what if I pay you on your day off to
come
um that's what I'm used to first off the
phone
um yeah
we can figure something out yeah dude
they will love to do side jobs like that
that's what I'm used to yeah dude I'm
just like man what if I pay you
everything I'm telling people right now
if you see a Mexican you know they come
in from a company and before you tell
them on your day off if you come can you
do it for half they'll do it they love
side jobs yeah my dad never stopped
working I'm like she's like oh this you
work for air conditioning company you
don't work on the weekends your business
hours are Monday through Friday but on
Saturday
what if something fell off the truck and
just bounces up in my house
is that a possibility the fight's like
uh yeah we can make it happen again
make it happen yes no problem but that's
a cool load that this is good I
encourage this I think this is a
wholesome story I like the idea of a
bunch of dudes that can't figure their
[ __ ] out so their wives got to come in
and organize it for them I feel like
that's a very household classic dude
it's so I'm telling any day now he's
gonna be piping girls and then it's
going to be trouble and hyping girls
great he's gonna be piping [ __ ]
they're just gonna book them for other
kind of we're gonna see them on Dr Phil
confessing and I it was just so hard not
to it's just it's like and then what
made you wanna [ __ ] the ladies they just
[ __ ] do throw themselves at me dude
so you want me to get nailed
follow the puns yes oh cheesy puns do
your white voice is like [ __ ] really
good I was in Arizona dude I was in
Arizona it's better than Colleen coming
from a white person yeah
not the 31.4 now yeah dude I grow with a
bunch of white people dude yeah so I
mean uh Laura age 38 she said I never
expected it to take off as much as it
has we've only been going four months
and it got to a point where there was so
much work coming in that James was
working six days a week we've had to
start turning jobs down and reduce our
hours so now we do Monday to Friday nine
to five we had our own building plans
that we've not even started just because
we've been so busy we booked our first
job for January too so they're booked up
months gotta do DIY what did he do
before does it say same [ __ ] he just
didn't have a brilliant marketing person
beyond the organizes scheduled the right
way that's the issue with contractors
though straight up they are horrible
with time and schedules yeah
you need someone like her that'll
organize his time and everything yeah
guys aren't very good just like plus
like rentmyhusband.com
you know what I mean I'm like I remember
that rape my husband but also though too
this guy's probably working all day when
he comes home you don't want to do the
marketing stuff you know of course he's
he's on site all day yeah he's the
talent he's working yeah he's an artist
you know what I mean build out but
that's the you know that's the benefit
of having a white lady she just knows
how to I'm gonna make a business I'm
gonna organize it I'm gonna make a PDF
and she just [ __ ] does this whole
thing breaks it down she probably like
brought this up during like dinner with
the PowerPoint like it's okay I have a
crazy idea here and then [ __ ]
PowerPoints or he's eating oh a sandwich
yeah whatever whatever you want to do
yeah
so like when do I do it like when I'm
off work yeah I'll do it I guess yeah
whatever you want baby we're gonna get
started
pimping the [ __ ] out of them
that's exactly how it went down dude I'm
telling you she gets excited great
looks like it runs off you did grow up
with whites yeah you did he's finishing
a sandwich confused talk through talk
through this photo shoot for marketing
what were they saying to each other
honey hold the hammer like this honey
good [ __ ] smile or do something
[Laughter]
when she pitched him he was so confused
you want me to [ __ ] no we're not you're
not [ __ ] them you're helping them
wait I don't want to get I'll go to
their house and then I I [ __ ] the wives
what are we doing what's going on like
no you're just building things for them
oh my God you're so stupid John all
right whatever you need
he keeps he's got he's confused about
[ __ ] yeah
wait so when do I [ __ ] them
John you're not [ __ ] them John this
is when we start [ __ ] that's all he's
thinking about I was like all right
oh all right I guess so just fix the
kitchen yes and that's it okay cool
and he's at the house and he goes it's
it's so no [ __ ] it's like John
John no see you guys
hey so I'm done do I just like leave
okay should we uh square up or
oh good oh no no cuddling or nothing can
I get like a hug or something
I guess whatever can I get a hug he even
tells him like Hey I'm here to fix not
not [ __ ] you know wait that's her slogan
when he comes in a house he warns him
he's just like hey it's me John here to
fix and no [ __ ] you white people are
good at marketing
he's spot on
that's good stuff on the nose not [ __ ]
Brett my husband not [ __ ]
it's not like you know how to run a
business yeah dude come on man just
gotta you know she looks like you work
with a lot of white ladies you gotta get
your uncles bro I know how white people
yeah what would the Mexican marketing
version be
my concrete rent my deals yeah rip my
deals not as catchy
well because you gotta Market it to
outside of Mexicans because every
Mexican knows how to build [ __ ] so you
have to go outside to like Silicon
Valley or something oh I got you yeah
that's smart you go out there they're
like I could fix your computer but I
don't know what to do about my house
dude those those type of Mexicans hang
out at office people you know what I
mean they [ __ ] be fixing computers I
can fix the computer printer I'd do it
see some cuter printer
Latinos they're not that they're not
that tech savvy you know what I mean
once they remove the ink they think they
know everything about computers easy
is easy you know what I mean
no Pisces it wouldn't I don't know I
don't think Mexicans would do this
would do this yeah they have to do
social media and stuff so I don't know
that's that they're done okay
they don't really know how to do social
media yeah and then plus they'll be
trying to like you know sleep with the
[ __ ] ladies and [ __ ]
they're gonna be like hitting him yeah
[ __ ] nothing yeah yeah
I'm Mr Stacy uh I'm done but we can do
other things if you
I could see that going down dude show up
in the door with no shirt I'm sorry I
explained something it's okay
[Laughter]
I'm sorry it's okay
oh and you're looking at my camera be
careful
be careful he's like hammering in a very
sexual way
oh my God
Jose you're hammering kind of heavy yeah
you like that I can go harder
your memory is so [ __ ] hard right now
that's a sexual [ __ ] tension
[Music]
[Music]